MARSH GARDINER: Hi.
My name is Marsh.
I'm a product manager
on the Apigee team.
And joining me today
is Evan from HP.
We'll be talking about
developer engagement
and how it supports
digital transformation.
Digital transformation
is a less violent way
of saying software
is eating the world.
It means adapting to business
opportunities presented
by digitally
enabled experiences.
And I've spent the
last 10 years helping
Apigee customers adapt
their existing businesses
to this new landscape.
While there are
tools that can help
with some of this
transition, there's
also a cultural shift
that's happening.
Digital transformation isn't
just a package install.
It's a change in
how people work.
Now, real, meaningful
change takes time,
but it also can
happen in bursts.
For the last few months, as
the world's faced a pandemic,
we've had to adapt faster.
How we live, how we work,
it's dramatically different
than it was in January.
To say we've been disrupted
would be an understatement.
And now, today, I'm much
more likely to see my family
and friends through a
screen than in person.
Adapting to shifts
and new technologies--
this has been going on
for a long, long time.
Automation really got
going in the 1800s
as the power loom transformed
the textile industry
to programmable looms such as
the Jacquard machine, which
then made it easier
to reproduce patterns.
This changed the way
people do their work.
If you fast forward to today,
now many physical objects
have digital interfaces.
I can ask the Google Assistant
to turn on my lights.
I've added a device
to my garage door
so that it opens when I
pull into the driveway.
APIs are how these things
talk to each other.
When I order
groceries on my phone,
APIs fire off the different
systems that make that happen.
Teaching all these systems
how to talk to each other
and how to enable these
digital experiences,
that requires
people, developers.
And today, Evan and
I will be talking
about how enabling
developers is a critical part
of this digital
transformation journey.
So creating this great developer
experience-- you build APIs--
these are products-- and
you bring them to market.
And keep in mind, there are
many go-to-market strategies.
You need to find the
one that works for you.
You might begin by trying to
improve your internal business
efficiency.
Or perhaps your
best opportunity is
to launch APIs that
support a partner program.
Or maybe the
opportunity is creating
APIs for a large
number of developers
that you've never met.
Each of these
approaches is going
to affect how you
think about what
will make a great developer
experience for each
of those channels.
So first, developers
are your customers,
whether they're for internal or
external or partner use cases.
They're the consumers
of your APIs.
Second you, need a way
to bring them to market.
That's a storefront.
Just like any product
in a marketplace,
those APIs to be discovered,
learned about, and adopted.
Third, we think of
a developer portal
as a storefront for APIs.
This is where you are building a
great developer experience that
makes onboarding easy,
helps people get through
to their first API requests.
And all the way
along that journey,
when they have problems,
how do they get support?
Productizing your APIs,
that's one part of it.
But in addition to being
valuable to developers,
your APIs have to
be discoverable.
Once a developer
finds your APIs,
they're going to need
great documentation.
They're going to need support
and other resources that
help them succeed.
You can't just go out and
buy digital transformation.
It's part of how you
change your business.
But there are tools that
can help you on your way.
Just as important, there
are hard-fought lessons
you can learn from
companies who have
been going through these
transformations, like HP.
They've been on this journey
for five, six, or seven years
at this point.
And with that, I'd
like to turn it over
to Evan who can talk to you
about how HP uses developer
experience to drive their
digital transformation
strategy.
Evan, great to have you.
Good morning.
EVAN SCHEESSELE:
Thank you, Marsh.
Yeah, really appreciate
the opportunity to speak--
Google's invitation,
and about this topic
that we both share so
much enthusiasm for.
Myself, Evan
Scheessele, I've worked
at HP for about 20 years.
And in my space is developer
engagement and API strategy
generally.
It's part of our company's
work in digital transformation.
In fact, I work in our Office
of Digital Transformation
and Transformation Organization.
Today, I'm going to talk
about what this journey has
been like for us.
And what's important is that
it's not a done journey.
It's underway.
There's a lot we've
been learning.
And that means that there
have been course corrections
along the way.
And that's an important
aspect that I really
want to have come through.
Specifically, though,
there's a few points
I just want to make sure
that you are attending to
and that you take away by the
end of this brief session.
Like Marsh said,
APIs aren't projects.
They're products.
And there's a rich
embodiment of that
that we've really
learned to embrace.
API management is
essential, absolutely.
But as an enabler of
this product lifecycle,
there's a marketplace in play
here that involves developers.
And it might not
be what you think.
And developer
experience is a thing.
It's an important frame to
moving in a digital direction
and working with
APIs and developers
and creating that value that
enterprises seek to unlock.
Now, this sounds like
an interesting story
coming from HP.
And we're a hardware
company, right?
Back in the '30s we got
started, Bill Hewlett and Dave
Packard going to the
origins of Silicon Valley.
In fact, the first
garage, if you've ever
heard of a startup in a garage,
the first Silicon Valley garage
were our founders
starting a company
and selling their first
product, that gray box
there, to Disney
to make Fantasia--
and constant adaptation
and adjustments
to their product
thinking along the way.
What you see here
are, you know--
we're known for computers
and printers now.
But on the screen,
you know, these
are oscilloscopes and
calculators and our wrist
watch.
It's a company that really
does embrace our motto,
"keep reinventing."
And that's been
essential to our movement
into digital and accelerating
in this direction
in the last 10 or so years.
What we are today--
a lot of business-minded people
think about HP as the PC maker.
And indeed, we sell more
PCs than any other company
on Earth.
July 2020, just last month, we
held the number one position.
And we obviously,
to most folks, know
that we have a huge
printing business,
from tiny little
handheld consumer
printers to presses that fill
factories, to 3D printing.
That printing business
is essentially
based on this idea
of placing hardware
so that we can have a
supplies revenue stream, kind
of like the classic business
school razors and blades model,
right?
You sell the Better
so that you can
get that annuity
stream of revenue
from selling the blades.
Or often, I think, also the
coffee maker and the coffee
pods is very similar.
Well, with HP, you know,
we're known for ink,
placing printers so that
that ink sales happens.
And what's great
about it, of course,
is we believe we do make
an important contribution
to society in this space,
because our content is
physical.
HP makes, you know, the online
experience a little more real
when you can print a photo.
And likewise, we're moving in
directions investing heavily
beyond just simple, you
know, classic printing.
In some cases, we sell ink
by the 1,000 liter tote.
And we sell materials
for 3D printings
in our nascent 3D
printing business
in the industrial side--
a lot of growth there in
this physical content space.
But in a business
model point of view,
it's still about placing the
units and a lot of revenue
and a lot of business
happening through the use
and consumption of supplies.
Now, all this is great.
But this is a
software talk, right?
What does any of this
have to do with software?
Well, it's where
we're coming from.
And it's an important
foundation for our direction
that we're heading now.
Now, HP has had software
in mind for decades.
We've even-- you know,
we've packaged software
with our devices.
We've had to write device
drivers with operating system
partners.
Often, though, software
is seen as an accessory
to be included in the box at the
lowest possible expense, just
a necessity that wasn't central
to the value proposition
of printers or PCs and such.
It's got to evolve from there.
Where we're coming from
is this old model, right,
this idea that there's a
factory and on the inside
we invent things.
We make them then we
ship them out the door
to the outside world.
You know, marketing
brings it to market.
We either have a direct or
indirect channel sales--
classic antiquated physical
hardware industrial model.
So we're learning
to add software
as a principle to
this model, right?
Let's add another dimension.
And keep that
hardware side, right?
We're still a mechanical
engineering, you know,
strong manufacturing company.
But if we think of software as
its own piece to this equation,
now we can think of in the
factory or back office software
investments, which are essential
to a multinational company
like ours.
But also, there's
the outside software,
like going to market
with software,
having digital businesses,
this cloud modern 2020
approach to building and growing
businesses based on software.
So now we have a way
of thinking about it.
Now, how do we make it real?
Well, we start with
our foundation.
We have our hardware
placed all around the world
from small to large, consumer,
commercial, industrial.
How do we grow these digital
businesses, these software
motions on top of it?
Well, it starts
with extensibility.
How are we going to bring new
value through our hardware?
Well, this hardware has
to be software extensible.
And that means
partnering, right?
Who's going to use
those extensions?
Who's going to
participate with us?
It's our business partners.
Well, who among those
business partners?
Well, those are the
developers, really, right?
We have to be working
with developers
to create these new experiences
to address those markets.
And ultimately, what do
those developers need?
What do they consume?
It's our friend, the API.
So this has been one of
our year's past epiphanies,
really getting our heads
wrapped around APIs aren't just
integration necessities,
like a new supplier needs
to be able to submit
an invoice and so they
have to call an API to
get paid or something.
No.
It's about growing ecosystems
and creating new value
in the business motion.
So really, we've
recently gotten our hands
around the fundamental
value proposition of APIs.
And so we're going to
really work with that.
In fact, we started to adopt a
mindset of, build those APIs.
Place those APIs.
And they'll create value,
like that classic ink revenue
stream of placing
printers and seeing
their usage create revenue
through supplies, consumption.
So maybe the API is the new ink.
Well, let's manage that.
If it's going to be that
fundamental and that critical,
then we're going
to learn about APIs
and ensure we have structure
to manage and control
and really run them.
So API management, right?
This is how we came to start
working with Apigee and Apigee
Google.
And our work is this imperative
to ensure that we have a firm
grasp on our API strategy.
Management is essential, right?
These assets are too important.
And so we did our research.
We really came to find that
the Apigee's enterprise savvy
data model and structure
for federation and security,
authentication, a
lot of great features
that map to our kind of
enterprise scale complexity.
Really important
work to get our arms
all wrapped around the
API management space.
And again, just classic back
office muscle that we had,
like, we need a new ERP.
We know how to bring
that in and bring it up
to speed to serve our business.
API management--
same kind of motion.
Research, adopt, build
out that capability.
And you know, the outside
world tells us this
is an appropriate motion.
Here's Gartner's view of
enterprise or digital business
landscape.
Platform thinking, like a
robust API management suite
is a software platform, not
just a tool you use wire in.
And where does it fit
on a full enterprise
view of this landscape?
Well, it's in that
partnering facet,
where API management
and the developer
portal components go, whether
it's customer facing or it's
internal or partner facing.
Like, that that's the
side of this landscape
that we're operating.
And it was reassuring
to see that, you know,
enterprise business
strategists and deep thinkers
are putting this work as
a major facet of our go
forward investments.
So for us, that meant
a lot of investment
in understanding the data model
and the controls, the knobs,
how do we structure our
thinking around API management.
Obviously, Apigee is
a product foundation.
But it's got this organizational
or data model structure
that, for a
non-trivial enterprise,
you have to wield that
appropriately and make
it fit into your
organizational landscape.
And then deeper
in the data model,
there's all of these
other elements that
serve an important
purpose and allow
us to hone toward getting
the most value out
of the management platform,
the most visibility
and observability and security.
These are essential pieces.
But then what we've
learned, as we've
been doing this for the
last five years now,
we learned that this wasn't
necessarily the goal, right?
You know, rolling
this out and making
those in those
integrations work,
rolling it out, making
the integrations work,
and ensuring the
controls are in place
was necessary, but wasn't
our final objective.
Oh, something's missing there.
And our developers, our
own internal developers,
kind of helped
remind us of this.
And that is this idea that I
mentioned that, really, there's
a product management story.
And if there's a product,
that means there's a customer.
And if there's a customer,
there's a customer experience.
So, you know, your
MBA types are going
to-- lightbulbs are going
off and saying, that's right.
Customer experience matters,
no matter what back office
IT process or HR
process or anything.
There's always a relationship
and there's an experience.
And so we've recently
pivoted to started--
really internalized the
thinking that API management
is a foundation on which
we build a product value
proposition, and that the API is
the product, not just a managed
element of our model, of our
operations and integrations.
So we've moved
API management now
as this foundational enabler.
It's like this, you
know, well-built road
on which commerce can run.
On that, now, we can build
software development standards
and process automation
pipelines that
will ensure consistent
software projects and services.
And then on that is the
real work of product
management, the full lifecycle
from birth to getting it out
in front of customers
to iterating
to even sunsetting products.
This is our new frame.
The API isn't the
tip of that pyramid.
Really, it's the product that
has those relationships rolled
up in it.
So it's about relationships.
It's about relationships
with developers.
And that means that
this original work
of understanding the data
model remains in place.
But we've learned to
start shifting our focus
to another dimension, right?
It's going up in
the business model
stack into seeing
those relationships
and measuring the
engagement with the product.
We're now up into even
net promoter score space.
We're thinking about the product
and the value it's creating.
This is a graph that
is fundamentally
a different view on the work.
This is about the relationships
between different kinds
of developers and the APIs
and the product embodiment
of those APIs, but
also the runtime--
real time nature of APIs.
And we've even learned to
embrace that developers
come in different types.
There's the developers
who make your APIs
and the developers who
consume those APIs.
And they have different
kinds of relationships
and different stages
of life cycles.
Reliability and security
remain essential, right?
The runtime remains essential,
but our focus is now--
or maybe our sight
line has shifted
to better see how the value is
really created by this work.
Now, some of you
might say, well,
isn't this developer relations?
We're talking marketing now?
And no, we're really thinking
still about the platform.
But in a sense, yes, we're
enriching our platform thinking
with a concept of
relationships and developers'
experience with the product
as a first order concern.
There is a classic
value chain view
that might be familiar
to some of you.
This is a reflection of
Apigee's original digital value
chain, where we've got
users who consume apps built
by developers who
consume the API that
is offered by these publishers.
And what we're doing now and
how we're investing our energy
looking at this space
from 2020 going forward
is we're really looking at a
couple of different developer
journeys.
There's the consumer
developer journey
and there's this publisher
side, the creator side.
They're developer
experiences each,
but they're also different.
And you know, this
is a different step
or a different element
entirely of working with APIs
than thinking about
just publish APIs
and the value is
inherent, right?
We're no longer just
thinking about shipping APIs
like we'd ship a
printer hardware
and there would be
value inherent in that.
We're thinking about the
actions of these consumers,
of these publishers, as
being the measured value
is happening there.
In fact, there's a
gap in this diagram
that is the missing piece.
And it's where they
find each other.
And where's the
classic business school
concept of where suppliers
and consumers find each other?
Well, it's a marketplace.
I use the word marketplace
very generally.
We're always thinking in
terms of a developer portal,
more or less.
But it's a marketplace
of ideas is
what I've learned to adopt
as a philosophy for why
the portal serves
the features it has
and how you measure its success.
It isn't just uptime.
It isn't just performance
of page views and such.
It's, are consumers
finding what they're
looking for and unlocking
value from a catalog of assets
published by our
developer community?
If HP is going to
offer APIs, we need
to offer APIs that are
products which unlock value.
And they only matter--
even the best API product
doesn't matter unless
it's consumed by somebody
who is having that
value, is experiencing it
and solving their problems.
So really, this puts in
perspective this portal work,
right?
Why does this portal
fit into this equation?
It's because it's where
these two communities can
meet each other in a
credible, believable--
it will be that
marketplace where
my participating community
finds what we're doing.
Also, beyond the portal, is
just a place for discovery.
We're also learning
that it unlocks insight
through instrumentation.
Analytics happens throughout
the digital value chain.
But at the portal where
products are being published
and iterated and our internal
and external partners are
finding them, evaluating them,
and choosing and engaging
with our APIs,
there's rich analytics
that come out of
that that better
inform how well this
platform is working
and what further
investments are needed.
So looking forward,
simplifying our energy here,
we're putting energy into
that discovery and engagement
part-- the portal not just
as, again, a web platform,
but as a place for both the
consumers and the publishers
to efficiently and confidently
perform their work, right,
either searching for or finding
and getting on with life using
some API or SDK, but
also the publishers who
need to know that this
is how the catalog works.
This is the ultimate
catalog where
I want my work to be
discovered on, and as
efficiently and as consistent
and securely as possible.
On the other side, we
think about the developers
in community.
We have to invest in
their resources for Q&A
and consistent standards and
topic tagging between things
so that search works.
Good, solid answers are
always available when
needed on how to run and
be a successful developer
in our company.
And connecting it--
the interstitial fabric
is analytics.
It's understanding
really what connects
all of these experiences.
We can instrument a lot of
our digital tool changer--
developers' code pipelines
and API run times and even web
analytics on the portal--
together, creating a really rich
graph that better illuminates
how well we are
addressing our customers,
our developer partners' needs.
So the takeaway
is, it's a journey.
And it's not about
any one end goal,
but it is about being willing
to reinvent how you think
about your partners, think
about opening interfaces,
think about APIs as products.
There is a whole
lifecycle in APIs
that recently has come to light
for us on how to invest in it,
you know, from end to end.
And API management--
absolutely essential.
Apigee has been a
powerful enabler for us
to meet our needs
for management.
But now we're also seeing how
it further extends that value
into the product lifecycle.
Developers need a
marketplace for their ideas,
whether you're
looking for something
or you're looking to ensure
your work is discoverable.
And the best way to understand
those developers' needs
and requirements
and expectations
is what we call
developer experience.
It supports all of those
different developer journeys.
And it's the right
kind of product frame
of mind for thinking about
unlocking your enterprise's
ultimate value as you
move from hardware
or whatever legacy business
structure to really
services that build on
top of your foundations
and help you move
forward and compete.
And with that, thank you
very much again, Marsh,
for the invite.
And if you have any questions,
you can reach out to me--
evan@hp.com.
MARSH GARDINER: Thanks, Evan.
It's really fascinating to hear
you talk through the journey HP
has been on and to
put it in the context
of the different
transformations that HP
has faced through years, like
the shift to delivering ink.
And it's really
great to hear how
you've walked through that
and given lessons to us
that we can learn from.
Thank you very much.
EVAN SCHEESSELE:
You're very welcome.
Thank you.